Puerto Rico here is currently a
territory of the United States but as
you'll probably know it isn't a state
much like Alaska and Hawaii it was
annexed in the second half of the 19th
century but unlike the other two
territories Puerto Rico never made the
leap from being a territory to a fully
fledged state so why not what stopped
Puerto Rico from becoming a state so to
begin Puerto Rico was a Spanish colony
up until 1898. this was after Spain and
the United States got into a bit of a
scuffle over a main sinking and a
general American desire for Empire
Building the Spanish tried to resist but
the United States won-handedly and in
the peace treaty it got Guam the
Philippines and Puerto Rico this was
shortly after Hawaii was annexed by the
US and 30 years after Alaska had been
two but where Hawaii and Alaska differ
from Puerto Rico is that the continental
U.S saw them differently and those that
live in their territories wanted
different things Hawaii for example was
largely ignored by the mainland United
States for decades and served as a
useful naval base in the North Pacific
with some limited resources whereas for
Alaska the US government took a much
Kinder stance towards it in the 194 40s
because of the advances in aviation the
US was concerned about Japan the Soviet
Union and to a lesser extent Britain
during this time and Alaska was well
positioned to deal with them it was a
similar distance from all three of them
so it made a good transport Hub and also
it was useful for stationing long-range
bombers there just in case in 1958
Alaska was offered a referendum on
stated which 80 wanted and so it was
soon accepted very shortly after this
Hawaii was offered the same now this was
slightly more controversial since many
American lawmakers were worried about a
majority non-white State sending
senators and congressmen to do things
like vote on laws and stuff however the
U.S was under pressure from the United
Nations to decide what Hawaii was going
to be and So to avoid accusations of
Empire President Eisenhower offered the
territory a vote on becoming a state
over 90 percent of Hawaiians supported
the move and so in 1959 it joined as
America's 50th state so why didn't
Puerto Rico get the same treatment the
United Nations also took a dim view of
America keeping it as a territory but
the difference was in the attitudes of
the Puerto Ricans to the United States
from before its annexation until the
outbreak of World War One the island had
a strong independence movement and very
few people there wanted to become
Americans yet after Puerto Ricans were
given citizenship in 1917 the desire for
Independence slowly faded and people
came to prefer release association with
the United States this didn't mean that
everybody was happy with the arrangement
and when the island status was reviewed
in the 1950s small-scale armed revolts
broke out across the island despite this
most Puerto Ricans were happy to remain
a U.S territory they didn't get any seat
in Congress but no representation meant
no taxation and so those who lived there
didn't have to pay federal income tax as
for the opinion of successive U.S
governments they didn't want to deal
with the potential upheaval that extra
senators and congressmen would bring and
during the 1950s and 1960s when certain
political and social issues with the
Forefront of American thought there were
concerns about emitting another state
whose population was overwhelmingly
non-white and whose population was about
three times larger than both Alaska and
Hawaii's combined as such in the
American political tradition it was time
for can kicking something which
continues to this day is opinions on the
island slowly move towards being more
and more pro-stated I hope you enjoyed
this episode and a special thanks to my
patrons James bisonet Kelly moneymaker
Sky Chappelle kosher wolf Jerry lambden
Jordan Longley Adam Stalter Marcus
Arsenal Y in hockey Spencer Lightfoot
rod D Martin words about books podcast
Captain side dog Gustav Swan Marvin
Castle commune Winston K wood boogly
Wiggly Daniel to be in Miss is it Aaron
the white Corey Turner the macquapa Alex
Schwinn Anthony Beckett Coppertone
Maggie Paskowski she went in spinning
three plates and Charles the first